love this place don't you
I know it's kind of expensive but
everything's so top-notch hey folks
know what you want yes I'd like to eat
the down payment on a house with a side
of phenom bait emergency fund excellent
choice
and for you sir I'm pretty hungry so I'm
going to have our retirement savings and
what the heck a bottle of our daughter's
college tuition very good do you think
we spend too much on dining out
maybe but everyone else is doing it
besides what's the alternative cooking
at home least the breadsticks are free
[Music]
21 percent of Americans have no
retirement savings and another 10% have
less than $5,000 it's even bleaker for
Millennials nearly 6 and 10 have nothing
saved at all now there are a lot of
reasons for this
the increasing cost of housing health
insurance and of course student debt but
for many people those costs are
relatively fixed if you're looking for
practical areas to cut back one sticks
out like a fly in your soup dining out
in 2015 for the first time in history
Americans spent more money on bars and
restaurants than on groceries with the
average household now spending more than
three thousand dollars annually on food
away from home representing between five
and seven percent of their total
spending even though Restaurant prices
are increasing faster than inflation and
grocery prices are holding steady or
even falling the average diner is still
eating out around five times a week how
much is this costing us well restaurants
typically mark up their food by around
three hundred percent meaning the price
on the menu is about three times what
they actually spent on the food if that
seems like a lot remember you're also
paying for the restaurants rent labor
equipment and overhead so if you live in
an area where real estate values are
increasing that also applies to the
surface area of your local restaurants
table top
and that doesn't even include drinks a
survey by Zagat found that the average
restaurant bill per person is over $36
if you do this just three times a week
it's over 5,600 dollars a year by
contrast the average meal cooked at home
with groceries from the market is about
$1 a person now you can see why so many
financial advisors focus on dining out
as a place to save money how much money
could you potentially save I think it's
time to run the numbers
let's say Jake here goes out for dinner
three times a week spending $35 each
time he starts every workday with a
latte and croissant at his local coffee
shop and buys lunch at the local food
court four days a week
Fridays are pizza day at the office and
one year he spent over $9,000 on
commercially prepared food and drinks
over 12% of his yearly salary of $75,000
what if Jake could get those three
dinners down to just for one a week and
what he started making coffee and
breakfast at home and brown-bag lunches
at work assuming that all those homemade
meals would come out to around $5 each
that would mean a yearly savings of four
thousand four hundred and twenty dollars
that's enough for a Hawaiian vacation
but wait we're not done what if Jake
took those yearly savings and put them
into an account earning 7% compound
interest in just ten years he'd have
over sixty five thousand dollars enough
for a down payment on a house in 20
years he'd have almost $200,000 all from
just eating at home more often
Jake's example demonstrates that even in
an era of burdensome health care and
student loan obligations you might have
some wiggle room in your finances even a
small cut back in dining out could allow
you to finally pay off an onerous debt
or build an emergency fund this might be
easy advice to give but harder to put
into practice many of us dine out
because we're too busy or tired to cook
after a long day of work if we know how
to cook at all and going to restaurants
isn't just about the food it's a social
event a place to see your friends to
connect with coworkers take the edge off
a stressful day so we're not saying
never go out to eat but if you want to
cut down on this expense you first have
to know why you're spending the money in
the first place is it a convenience or a
luxury if it's a convenience in other
words if you're eating out because you
don't have time to cook at home well the
problem might be a lack of preparation
after all brewing a pot of coffee and
toasting a bagel can be less
time-consuming than waiting at a
Starbucks line and can potentially save
you hundreds of dollars there are lots
of resources on the web for how to make
shopping and cooking cheap and simple
including this video we made about
navigating the super mark
but if you're still intimidated by the
prospect you could ease yourself into it
by utilizing ingredient or grocery
delivery services like blue apron or
instacart these are definitely more
expensive than doing your own shopping
but still cheaper than eating out we
like to use cash at the supermarket to
stay within a budget but if you're
trying to incentivize yourself you could
look into a credit card that gives
rewards for grocery purchases and it's
always a good idea to keep some
convenience foods like microwavable
dinners in your freezer that way on days
that you really don't feel like cooking
you'll have an alternative to stopping
for take-out or ordering it on the other
hand if eating out is a luxury that is
if you're doing it for social or
psychological needs there still might be
ways to achieve that with less spending
for instance you can share an entree
restaurant portions are typically much
larger than the average diners appetite
because it makes it easier for
businesses to justify high prices if
you're there for the service and
atmosphere you can get that without
overeating to the point of discomfort or
leaving uneaten food behind if you have
favorite restaurants you know you visit
often it might be a good idea to sign up
for their email lists or check Groupon
for details but beware that these
bargains are intended to make you visit
more frequently same goes for diners
rewards cards if you're not careful
these strategies might actually increase
your monthly dining expenses alcohol is
one of the biggest markups for
restaurants so if you like to have a
drink with dinner you might want to find
places that allow you to BYOB similarly
going to an ice-cream show up after
dinner is usually much cheaper than
ordering dessert at the table and lastly
if you find yourself buying lunch just
as an excuse to get out of the office no
one's forcing you to eat at your desk
hopefully take your brown bag to a
nearby park or public space it's the
same psychological benefit without the
cost dining out is a big part of our
culture and it may be an important
aspect of your social or professional
life so we're not suggesting you cut it
out cold turkey but you should accept
any large regular expense without asking
yourself three fundamental questions
how much am i spending on this what do I
get out of it and can I get the same
benefit for less money and that's our
two cents do you have any tips on how to
save money while dining out go ahead and
share them with us in the comments
[Music]